WILL BEGIN IN SIXTY SECONDS. SO
IF OTHERS MEMBERS WHO ARE NOT
HERE CAN BE CALLED SO I CAN
ESTABLISH FORUM.
THE JOINT
LEGISLATIVE BUDGET COMMITTEE
WILL NOW COME TO ORDER- AND- IN
RESPONSE TO THE CODE NINETEEN
EMERGENCY. AND TO PROTECT THE
PUBLIC LEGISLATORS AND
EMPLOYEES WE WILL LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND IT
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING AND
FACE COVERING GUIDANCE. IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE IS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THE PUBLIC
CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS TO THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. WE ARE
HOLDING OUR COMMITTEE HEARINGS
HERE IN THE CAPITAL WITH SOME
MEMBERS ABLE TO PARTICIPATE
REMOTELY. TODAY ALL OF OUR
MEMBERS WILL BE HERE IN THE
CHAMBERS FOR THE KING HEARING
ROOM AND THERE WILL NOT BE ANY
MEMBERS PARTICIPATING REMOTELY.
TO ALLOW PUBLIC ACCESS WE HAVE
ADMITTED MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
TO TWO HEARING ROOMS. TO THE
EXTENT THAT SOCIAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS ALLOW AND SINCE
THIS IS A MEETING WHERE WE ARE
IN- SURELY ORGANIZATIONAL AND
WE ARE JUST ADOPTING OUR RULES.
AND OUR- ELECTING OUR CHAIR AND
VICE CHAIR WE WON'T BE TAKING
PUBLIC COMMENT- BUT FOR
INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO LISTEN
TO TODAY'S PROCEEDINGS YOU CAN-
VIEW IT ON THE WEBSITE BUT ALSO
YOU CAN CALL IN AND I WILL READ
A NUMBER THAT YOU CAN CALL IN
SO YOU CAN LISTEN TO IT NOW
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS. EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN TWO TWO SIX EIGHT
ONE FIVE TWO. THEN THE ACCESS
CODE IS. ONE ONE SEVEN FOUR
SEVEN SEVEN ONE. NOW LET'S SEE
IF WE HAVE- WE'RE IN A POSITION
TO ESTABLISH OUR QUORUM. NINETY
YET. THE. WELL I WILL INDICATE
THAT- AS I HAVE SAID THAT OUR
PURPOSE FOR TODAY IS TO ADOPT
OUR COMMUNITY COMMITTEE RULES
AN ELECTRIC CHAIR AND VICE
CHAIR AND DUE TO THE TIMING OF
THE HEARING AND CONFLICTING
CALENDARS WERE GONNA POSTPONED
THE PORTION OF THE HEARING.
THAT WE HAD INITIALLY SCHEDULED
WHICH IS A PRESENTATION BY OUR
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST MR PECK ON
THE ROLE OF THE JOINT
LEGISLATIVE BUDGET COMMITTEE
AND AN OVERVIEW OF IT INSTEAD
WE WILL SCHEDULE THAT
DISCUSSION FOR A LATER TIME SO
THAT WE CAN GIVE THAT UP
OVERSIGHT AND DESCRIPTION THE
ATTENTIONIT DESERVES. SO LET
ME SEE IF WE HAVE A QUORUM NOW.
WE STILL NEED TO MORE FOLKS.
THREE TWO THREE FOUR FIVE SIX
SEVEN. ONE TWO THREE FOR. YEAH
I THINK- HI DO YOU HAVE FOR
ONCE YOU'RE FORCIBLY. AND.
YEAH.
YEAH. YEAH. YEAH.
THE OKAY.
SIR
WE ARE JUST WAITING FOR A
COUPLE OF ASSEMBLY MEMBERS IN
ORDER TO ESTABLISH QUORUM. AND
THEN AS I INDICATED WE WILL BE.
BECAUSE THIS IS JUST AN
ORGANIZATIONAL SESSION AND WILL
BE VOTING ON ADOPTING THE RULES
AND ON THE ELECTION OF CHAIR
AND VICE CHAIR SO AS SOON AS WE
CAN ESTABLISH A QUORUM. WE WILL
DO THAT.
THIRTY I'M- SO MR
CONSULTANT IF YOU COULD. SO WE
WILL NOW HAVE THE CONSULTANT TO
READ THE ROLE SO THAT WE CAN
ESTABLISH CORE. SENATOR SKINNER
I'M HERE SCANNER HERE SENATOR
BATES. SENATOR KABIRU SENATOR
DURAZO HERE TERRAZZO HERE
SENATOR LAYERED HERE WHERE HERE
SENATOR NELSON. NIELSEN HERE
SENATOR PAM. SENATOR PAN HERE
SENATOR PORTENT TINA POURTANT
TINO HERE ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
TANG. TANG HERE MERIMBULA HERE
ARENA HERE BLOOM FONG FONG E
SOMEONE NEVER CURSED HERE. I
SEE IT HERE KYLIE. MCCARTY
REVOLVES. I'M SORRY THE CARD IS
HERE WITH US. CORMAN'S A
STYLISH ALL RIGHT NOW THAT WE
HAVE ESTABLISHED A QUORUM AS I
INDICATED THE- GOAL OF OUR
HEARING TODAY IS TO ORGANIZE
THE COMMITTEE BY ADOPTING OUR
COMMITTEE ROLES IN ELECTING OUR
CHAIR AND VICE CHAIR- THE FIRST
MATTER OF BUSINESS FOR THE
ORGANIZATION IS THE ADOPTION OF
THE COMMITTEE RULES. THE
COMMITTEE LAST ADOPTED ITS%
RULES IN TWENTY NINETEEN. THEN
SO IS THIS BECAUSE THIS IS THE
FIRST YEAR OF A TWO YEAR
SESSION THAT IS WHY WE ARE RE
ADOPTING THEM THERE ARE NO
CHANGES TO THE RULES BEFORE US
TODAY. SO I WOULD LIKE TO SEE
IF THERE'S ANY OBJECTION TO
ADOPTING THE COMMITTEE RULES BY
UNANIMOUS CONSENT. ANY
OBJECTION. SEEING NONE. THEN
THE COMMITTEE RULES ARE ADOPTED
BY UNANIMOUS CONSENT. SIR NOW
WILL GO TO THE NEXT BUSINESS OF
OUR ORGANIZATIONAL SESSION AND
THAT IS THE ELECTION OF THE
CHAIR OR ORGANIZATIONAL HEARING
SKEWS ME THE ELECTION OF THE
CHAIR AND VICE CHAIR. AND
BECAUSE THIS IS A FISCAL
COMMITTEE WITH RESPONSIBILITIES
RELATED TO THE IMPLEMENTATION
OF THE ENACTED BUDGET. IT IS A
LONG STANDING TRADITION THAT
THE CHAIR. OF THE JAIL BC IS
THE CHAIR OF THE SENATE BUDGET
COMMITTEE AND THE CHAIR OF THE
ASSEMBLY BUDGET COMMITTEE
SERVES AS THE J. L. B. C. VICE
CHAIR. SO I'D LIKE TO SEE IF
THERE IS ANY OBJECTION TO
ELECTING. THE SENATE BUDGET
COMMITTEE CHAIR TO SERVE AS
CHAIROF THE JAIL BC BY
UNANIMOUS CONSENT IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION TO THAT. SEEING NINE
THEN WE HAVE ELECTED THE CHAIR
OF THE JAIL BC TWO F. IS THE
SENATE BUDGET CHAIR BY
UNANIMOUS CONSENT. THEY'RE NOW
WILL MOVE TO THE MATTER OF THE
ELECTION OF THE VICE CHAIR.
YEAH AS I INDICATED THE
TRADITION IS THAT THE VICE
CHAIR IS THE ASSEMBLY BUDGET
COMMITTEE CHAIR. SO IS THERE
ANY OBJECTION TO ELECTING THE
ASSEMBLY BUDGET COMMITTEE CHAIR
AS VICE CHAIR OF THE JAIL BC BY
UNANIMOUS CONSENT IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION. SEEING NONE THEN
OUR- VICE CHAIR. IS THE CHAIR
OF THE ASSEMBLY BUDGET
COMMITTEE AND IT IS ELECTED- SO.
THAT WAS THE BUSINESS FOR TODAY
AND AS I INDICATED I KNOW IF
YOU IF YOU WERE HERE EARLIER WE
ARE GOING TO HAVE ANOTHER
COMMITTEE HEARING TO HEAR FROM
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST ON THE
HISTORY OF THE JAIL BC AND ITS
PURPOSE BUT WITH THAT I THANK
YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE AND YOUR
COOPERATION WE'VE CONCLUDED THE
AGENDA FOR TODAY'S HEARING. AND
THE JOINT LEGISLATIVE BUDGET
COMMITTEE IS ADJOURNED.